you know one day one post something cool
and somebody cool
Drake sees it does it and everything
changes yeah but you have to do it every
day to have that moment
[Music]
that's a commotion
um my favorite part about the company is
just knowing we're headed towards
something that will be right about I
love that feeling I love the feeling of
like being on the right side of history
yeah and like think about pool assistant
which like I just don't think they are
and I think that um finding that balance
between the old world is a new world
excites me you know like there's people
that grew up in this company that are -
and them my new chef like small little
things and the nurse people that come
from outside agencies that just think
it's about television and molding those
two together to like one vision excites
me you know yeah and like voice and like
they are and influencers all these new
ways to be creative you can't think
about it in weeks you got to thinking
about it in years give yourself four
years that changes everything so look
now I can make it the year without a job
and you know that is it that was that
can make it you can make it longer a car
and food especially when you can control
that you can make you'll need any money
right yeah you have a roof over your
head you have a great situation with
your parents you don't want to be there
but it doesn't matter that's that's your
opportunities
you know you don't need it you can make
it for years I mean you can eat 99 cents
a day to morons
you could you could yeah you could it
depends on how bad you want it ya know
it's it's yeah well then you have to
make a four-year commitment okay because
then you'll go slow
you'll go fast but slow here that's with
their hands slow in your head okay so I
wouldn't expect it to work tomorrow it's
better to work Annie oh that's right
okay got it that's the key 16 hours a
day
okay so it's just when you say 36 is
young it changes everything
I believe that I lost the last five
years of my life
[ __ ] I don't want to do just that the
fact that you're exactly don't even
don't even think about that
yeah those five years pass so fast that
you know the next five years will pass
very fast to summarize well do something
that yes you have to go there's nothing
there's no as long as you can deal with
this
you like the only thing you're dealing
with is the stigma of being at home
everything else is easy yeah look I'm
the beneath and for us it's very normal
to stay at home until you get married
that's it that's it man it's really it's
really it's like it's like put it's like
getting it the shape you have nice
muscles just work just work but it's
patience the the the dollar 80 strategy
works in five years not in five days
okay together I mean content every day
for nine years before it started really
happening
okay it's not sexy it's just basic but
it works and you got the skinny gut
craft and there's a lot of people that
have craft so you have to chip chip chip
Jenna all right you know one day one
post something cool and somebody cool
Drake sees it does it and everything
changes
yeah but you have to do it every day
to have that moment
right there push it there and say like
pre-order than like it's like no it's
not another thing guys what's up I'm
just sitting here like with the team you
could show them it's fine but wanted to
make this very important video which is
a complete and interesting thing that's
running through my mind over and over
and over and over and over and over over
the last three or four months which is
why you're not willing to take one step
backwards for a step for the rest of
your life this thigh that's so many
you're miserable and your golden
handcuffs cuz you make 180 a year and
you mortgages and you have the car
payments some people get BMWs when they
shouldn't things like that blows my mind
so many of you are unhappy and you're
not willing to take one step back both
financially but more portly emotionally
you're worried what other people think
if you sell your home and you rent an
apartment you're worried what other
people think if you actually bring back
your Mercedes and really lease a Toyota
you're worried about if you move back in
with your parents or if you're not
married the job at thirty-one you are
not willing to think about this you are
not willing to take a step backwards a
step backwards which then affords you
the ability to quit your [ __ ] job or
stop doing your [ __ ] startup and do
something else you love or you think you
can be good at this
in abilities this lack of humility this
overvaluing somebody else's opinion that
doesn't let you take us nobody wants to
take a [ __ ] step backwards how are
you not willing to take a step backwards
because of other people's opinions and
willing to ruin the next forty seven
years of your life take a [ __ ] step
backwards to take a step forward for the
rest of your life move in with your
[ __ ] parents like a stop take a step
backwards it's the smartest move you've
got your whole life in front of you and
you're worried about other people's
judgments if you're living in your
parents home or you're driving not as
fancy of a car or you the left's [ __ ]
jewelry on your shirt because and you're
legit legitimately willing to ruin the
next fifty years of your life because of
other people's judgment in the short
term it's literally fundamentally the
stupidest [ __ ] thing you can do
[Music]
Wow